so I finished the book so whilst they
prepare for a few video I thought I
would just make a simple video on the
final chapter that looks like a future
of sleep last additional research they
did myself
and ended up taking a little bit longer
than I planned to make this video so I
hope you enjoyed the hard work that I
put into it it is uplifting I like to
think anyway anyhow let's just get going
with it so I'm going to be using Matthew
Walker's vision for sleep in the 21st
century as a framework to build upon
what generically the future of sleep
does look like in terms of improving
sleep quality and quantity so to be able
to achieve these improvements in sleep
quality and quantity that needs to be
interventions at a number of levels and
so these different levels that we'll
look at start with the individual level
and then they gain from educational to
organizational to public policies and
government to societal changes so
firstly let's look at what interventions
we might see at an individual level and
so the first thing we're going to
address is technology which gets a bit
of a bad press in terms of contributing
to bad sleep in the first place but we
can also use technology to advantage to
improve our sleep and so two negative
sides which I don't really want to fix
one in this video includes screen time
and the blue light emitted from our
screens that actually prevents sleep
onset but in this video were the more
the positives that technology can
provides for the future of sleep
improvement and this brings us to the
idea of personalized sleep medicine
where you have commercially available
affordable hopefully devices that come
in a numerous forms so in the future I
think is likely that technology that can
track a person sleep and connect that to
in-home network devices that could alter
the like their lighting systems and also
the temperature which we know is linked
to sleep and overall these smart homes I
expected to become more prevalent in the
future especially with the increase in
5g technology as well to help connect
these devices together
so besides smart homes
you may have heard of smartphones you
may have heard of Smart TVs and you may
have heard of smartwatches but now let's
meet the smart mattress is so smart
mattresses aren't covered in the book
and this is the bit where I got a little
bit distracted and found out about this
company called Sleep Number that have
these smart Matchett mattresses and I
caught distracted very much they ended
up doing their quiz and then they
recommended some mattresses that I might
like and so what's interesting about
these mattresses as well what makes them
smart because they claim to be able to
improve your sleep
and so these smart mattresses have
technology inbuilt with them that's
connected to an app on your phone and
what you can do is you can adjust the
curvature of the mattress it records
your sleep movement your heart rate your
breathing rate and all this data gets
sent back to you and you can find out
how well you're sleeping but currently
in this book pricing and suppose I don't
really know much about this mattress
besides that they have a little video on
their website which you can watch as
well I guess if you would that
interested but I think I can definitely
see these becoming more prevalent in the
future but the general point that I'm
trying to make is that this past life
sleep medicine would be a way of
tracking your sleep I'm being able to
tailor the sleep environment that best
suits yourself on your own circadian
rhythm to help improve sleep quality and
quantity which is see April aim in terms
of improving health and lifestyle and it
can also be extended to cars in the
future like when you get to work in the
morning you could have bright blue
lights in the morning when you need it
to help break you up and then have that
dim amber yellow light in the evening
when you want to give bed as it as many
possibilities with the way that you can
tailor these devices I think you know
it's not the way and see what happened I
think be very interesting I'm talking
about the light systems one fun example
is NASA well maybe more interesting than
fun
but did you know astronauts on the
International Space Station orbit the
Earth say fast that they get the
brilliant delights of having 16 sunrises
and sunsets within the space of one day
so NASA decided it'd be best to develop
a lie system so that they didn't have to
enjoy this and say that they could sleep
correctly and the cost of developing one
of these light bulbs was three hundred
thousand dollars around that so you are
hopefully the cost will go down a little
bit in the future
but a lot of these technological
advances that also needs to be more
education in terms of understanding
sleep and so that will come from books
engaging matches excellent use your
videos like this one but the progress is
hard to keep habits in how many new
what's good and what's bad but this is
also again where technology could come
to save us because one thing that we
know is that seeing us often believing
sometimes and what I mean by this is
that if you have personalized sleep
tracking data you could use that
information and make predictions about
how you're doing and have that feedback
because you know how people like to have
so many walks they do each day you could
also get that from your sleep patterns
and they you know what are your chances
of getting the flu this year I don't
know what the future's in terms of what
advances will have but it just goes to
show if you had that kind of data you're
more likely to act upon it because you
want to see good data not bad data so
continuing with education Matthew Walker
outlines in this book the importance of
having more school education in terms of
better sleep awareness and also better
sleep practice because this will help
them live longer and healthier but also
you'll be able to pass on that knowledge
to future generations as well because
the money that we can invest now in
teaching will definitely be recovered in
terms of saving money from the accidents
and diseases and productivity that will
the loss of productivity that comes with
poor sleep and if they want that to be
educational and entertaining I've got a
solid idea for a new
TV show for Netflix called sleep
education wow that's a sleep clinic I'm
taking what obviously I'm concerned but
the sides from the points I think it is
really important to have no education
and so now let's look at the
organizational interventions that could
be made in the future so Matt's outlines
three examples in this book the first
one is a sleep credit score that would
very much depend on breaking the myth
about sleeping less is more productive
Gwen fat there are so much evidence
that's having a better sleep improved
productivity and so the idea is that
companies could rewards people based on
their sleep amounts and continuity over
successive nights and that could be in
terms of financial rewards or increased
vacation days the second idea would be
to break the norm of the working 9 to 5
and to instead have flexible work hours
that seat the workers say they could
start early if they wanted to or finish
later
whatever works best and then the last
thing that he explains is about medicine
and how at the moment the boards we have
like intensive care units they have a
lot of noise or the bright lights and
how that actually inhibits recovery and
recuperation from multiple diseases I'm
saying if you can improve the sleep
environment and hospitals you can also
decrease the time that patients are
spent in the hospital and I'm yeah
reduce the cost globally and I think
that's definitely an area that needs to
be addressed at some point hopefully see
and then lastly looking at the public
policy and societal changes that should
be intervened mainly come at the point
of acknowledging the fact that drowsy
driving is responsible for more
accidents than either drugs or alcohol
and that is so important to raise
awareness and to have more campaigns to
share the importance of having a good
night's sleep and maybe he kind of jokes
I don't if he is taking in the future
there could be a breathalyzer for sleep
deprivation so you've been warned anyway
every this video was
some more interesting and entertaining
about the possibilities of the hitch was
leaked and so yeah this came mainly from
the last chapter of this book which I
will try and looking at some point but
as always thanks for listening